[Music]
hey you guys book review time once again
here's another one that was in my pile
from a long time ago uh that i read
probably back in the late 90s or early
2000s you know just a paperback that i
bought from back then and i remembered
it being like pretty good so i wanted to
do a reread on it so the one we're
talking about today
is
the hellfire club by a very well-known
horror writer peter straub or straub i'm
not actually sure how to pronounce that
you would think that i would because
i've read like most of his books and
stuff but uh yeah this one's got this
nice
i hate when they print that like right
on the book look how tacky and ugly that
is that just i don't know that drives me
crazy but i don't know so originally
this book came out
i think in 1996
yeah at least i don't know if it came
out in hardback first or whatever
probably because peter straub is kind of
like
well known and everything although i'm
pretty sure that i didn't read it until
several years later now like i said i
remember i read it probably in the early
2000s and i remember
liking it but not loving it and i
couldn't really remember what it was
about
i think again this is another this
happens to me a lot i don't maybe just
because i read a lot but i thought like
when i started reading it i was like oh
uh because it's called the hellfire club
i was maybe thinking about this other
book and i can't think of what it is um
that was sort of that i was thinking
about like sort of along those same
lines because i will say
in its kind of like as a detrimental
kind of thing the title is the hellfire
club but it really doesn't have anything
to do
much with a hellfire club like maybe
like you're thinking um it's not like an
occult type of thing it's actually
it's weird because it's almost kind of
like genreless i don't it's not
genreless but i think it's like kind of
a mashup of genres it's kind of like
a literary mystery um but then it's kind
of like a crime thriller like a serial
killer type of situation also so it's
kind of like i don't know and it's like
very much like his novella that i
reviewed a little while back which i
didn't love which is called mrs god this
is also kind of based around
the literary world or kind of like the
upper middle class uh connecticut
uh kind of people and like in publishing
and stuff like that so maybe that's why
i don't
that i can't like connect with the
characters as much just maybe because i
don't know these are like kind of upper
middle class people with all these upper
middle class problems and i'm just kind
of like okay although in this one it's
uh you know there actually is like a
serial killer running around and there
is like some other and i do like
literary mysteries in fact a recent book
that i reviewed called the magpie
murders which i think only came out like
a couple years back i kind of feel like
if you liked that you would probably
like this older one as well because it
has like a similar sort of vibe to it
it's very layered it's very complicated
there's a lot of like plot threads
that you really have to pay attention to
them because a lot of them are
interconnected um and it's quite a long
book i mean it's not long long but it's
like 500 odd pages and uh so and there's
a lot of stuff going on so you really
kind of have to be sort of on the ball
with all the characters and what the
situations are and all this other kind
of stuff
so basically what we have going on this
is kind of like some background of the
story but back in 1938
there was this
sort of writer's retreat type of place
called shorelands
and there was a bunch of writers that
were there uh during the summer of 1938
and apparently like something bad
happened like one of the women that was
there disappeared and nobody knew where
she ended up now even though most of the
writers that were there at the time
didn't really
amount to much of anything there was one
guy there named hugo driver who sort of
came out of nowhere and he ended up
publishing this book called night
journey which was like a fantasy novel
and it ended up being like this massive
massive success so much so that it was
almost kind of like a lord of the rings
kind of situation where like people
would read it and they'd become like
obsessed with it and they'd have like
that you know that he was talking about
there were driver houses where people
would live there and they would just
like dress up like the characters and
all this other kind of stuff so people
were like super super into it
so he wrote that and he got like really
famous so all that happened back in 1938
i think there's like a little bit of
like a prologue that takes place back in
1938 but mostly it takes place in the
present day uh and we're just kind of
like given glimpses of stuff that was
going because it's basically about
somebody investigating
sort of uh what happened at shorelands
back then that's kind of like the
through line
or kind of like the main i guess the the
incident that everything else like
springs from but they don't like go he
doesn't go like a really lot into that
so our main protagonist is a woman named
nora chancell
and she's married to this dude named
davey who is he um i guess his family
business is chancel house which is like
a publishing house and they were the
ones that published night journey by
hugo driver and it's kind of like
they're only it's like a smaller
publishing house so
this book and its two subsequent sequels
which is kind of a big plot point
um are kind of their main
big sellers so davey i think like his
grandfather maybe started the publishing
company and then like you know it was
his dad and then like he's he's not
running it now because his dad is still
alive but he's kind of working there
while all this stuff is going on too
with the stuff about hugo driver and
night journey and the stuffed shorelands
and everything like that
also in the uh connecticut suburb where
they live there's also been like a
serial killer going around killing and i
believe at the beginning of the book
he's killed like four victims and the
victims are always the same they're
always like middle-aged very very
successful business women who lived
alone um and he's and he usually like
cuts them all up and it's like a
horrific
scene and everything like that so
everyone's kind of freaking out like in
this sort of small community seeing
who's going to be next or whatever now
near the beginning of the book there
seems to be what is another attack
on a very close friend of nora's now the
weird thing about this though is that
even though her bedroom is just like
covered with blood
there is no body there so they're not
entirely sure uh if she got murdered or
just kidnapped it it would seem that
there's so much blood there that she
can't still be alive
but you know so it's so it's very
unclear what's going on so nora and
davey because they're friends of this
you know of the disappeared woman whose
name i think is natalie i can't there's
a lot of characters in this and i like
lost track of some of their names but i
think her name is natalie i'll just call
her that whether that's her name or not
but uh so since they were friends of
hers uh and since they had kind of seen
her you know so the you know police get
involved and they're kind of asking them
for any information or whatever
so as it goes on though that something
very strange happens natalie the woman
that they thought had been murdered
because her
her room was all covered with blood
she actually turns up alive
but she seems like she's not super in
her right mind
and she basically straight up accuses
nora of kidnapping her and hurting her
so at this point nora's just kind of
like uh pretty sure i didn't do that but
you know what i mean but i guess the
woman's like super convincing it turns
out later that nora did maybe have a
motive for doing that and it's like and
the way that even though this is not in
the first person
it's pretty much all from nora's point
of view and she has a weird she was like
a nurse in vietnam in vietnam
and uh she had kind of like an affair
with a well it wasn't unfair because i
don't think she was married or i don't
remember if he was married or whatever
but they kind of had a fling like back
then uh you know with uh he was a doctor
and it's so it's kind of like so he kind
of plays into the thing later on too
but because of this horrible thing that
happened to her she was uh raped by a
guy in vietnam not the guy she was
saying was like just this random dude
and she has a lot a lot of ptsd for it
from it it's really weird because i kind
of feel like the first third of this
book the theme of this book seems to be
this poor woman like at the middle of
this
like like every dude like in this
[ __ ] book just turns out to be like
pretty much all of them turn out to be
complete pieces of [ __ ] uh except like
maybe one or two like turn out okay but
everybody turns out to be like a piece
of [ __ ] in some way or another even who
her husband who was kind of an innocuous
sort of dude but he's sort of like
you know he's sort of like a wet noodle
and he's very very gas lady in the sense
that
even though she's been behaving like one
thing that was really striking to me is
that even though she's been behaving
like pretty normally like for the first
the first third of the book like she's
got like some issues but everybody's got
issues like nothing you know screams at
you like oh my god she's a crazy woman
uh but then like there's this big
confrontation where her husband is
basically like you're a crazy person and
you know you've been like saying all
this crazy [ __ ] in your sleep and you
need to go and she's just like what have
i what i don't i don't really know
what's going on so at some point it's
almost kind of like when natalie comes
back and like accuses her of kidnapping
her it's almost kind of like yeah pretty
sure i didn't do that but she's like
wait did i and maybe i just didn't
remember so it's like she's kind of been
like gaslit and like kind of messed up
for so long that it's like she almost
like considers that maybe i did do that
and just didn't remember so it's that
kind of thing uh so this whole brouhaha
goes on her husband i think maybe sort
of halfway thinks she maybe did it uh
there's one cop that thinks she didn't
but most of the other cops like the fbi
comes in and everything because they
think like i said this is another victim
of this serial killer that's been going
around
but then as it turns out she is at the
police station one day i believe she's
actually being arrested for it because
they find like you know she had a motive
and all this other kind of stuff which
you know you'll see how it is like
she she didn't know she had a motive
when it actually happened it was like a
motive after the fact if that makes any
sense but yeah so she has to go to the
police should they arrest her and while
she's there
um they're transferring they've caught
the serial killer his name is
dick dart
and they've determined because natalie
the victim is still alive and she's so
she wasn't one of his victims and all
this other stuff so they're transferring
dick dart to somewhere else and he busts
out and ends up kidnapping nora and like
just you know taking her at gunpoint or
whatever and so for a long portion of
the book probably okay so like the first
half the first third of it probably or
the first quarter of it is kind of like
buildup and like stuff about shorelands
um and then davey her husband telling
her about telling her about the stuff
that happened back then like shorelands
and the hellfire club and this girl that
he knew that was super weird and you
know there's just this weird place that
they went which like i said doesn't
factor hugely into the story but it is
kind of in there which like i said i'm
not really sure why he called it the
hellfire club because even though a
couple of clubs like that like hellfire
clubs are brought up it's not super
entwined with the plot or at least not
in a way that i was super cognizant of
so you know just say that going because
it's not like the title sounds a lot
cooler or it's not so much that it's
just that i think the title is a little
bit deceptive because the hellfire club
doesn't have a huge amount to do with
what's going on in the story so the
first uh part of it is kind of like all
set up you know establishing kind of how
do she davey is like how
uh strained the relationship is between
not only between davey and nora but also
between
them and uh davey's parents because
there's whole one whole thing about like
him being adopted maybe and some other
and he's like feels inadequate and his
dad's kind of a [ __ ] to him because he
feels like he's never good enough and
then nora gets on his ass because he
never stands up to his dad his dad's
like kind of a [ __ ] and also the mom
is kind of like a little bit wacky
and she has written this novel and nora
like ends up reading it and it's just
it's this crazy
novel like it's just crazy and so
there's a lot of like so like i said i
know i'm like maybe not describing this
adequately because this is a very
complicated it's a very complex story it
has like a lot of moving parts so
this is definitely one that you're gonna
need to
you know sit down and like read it
because you really have to keep track of
like all the plot tendrils and what's
going on and how everything connects to
one another uh because it's not
immediately obvious so at the point
where nora gets kidnapped by the serial
killer dick dart at that point it almost
becomes like a like a black cop i don't
want to say black comedy but it's almost
kind of like a like a road movie type of
thing but like a crime thriller because
dick dart like decides that he's going
to
um you know
he's like i want to say like i've seen
some reviews like that we're kind of
comparing him to hannibal lecter which
he sort of is he's a little bit over the
top he's kind of one of those dudes like
one of his things that like really
that like really made me like hate him a
lot was that one he's one of those dudes
he has like a photographic memory
he super like knows everything he's
really like really intuitive so it's
like he can
um yeah so in that way yeah he's kind of
like hannibal lecter where he like kind
of knows what you're thinking or
whatever so he kind of knows that but he
also he has like a lot of even though he
doesn't look that great himself like i
guess he's like sort of handsome but
he's kind of like pudgy or whatever but
he has like some very definite ideas as
to what women should look like and he
doesn't like it that nora
is
nora is not ugly they don't say that but
she's just not she doesn't have like a
lot of patience for doing like really
free through feminine stuff like she's a
little bit of a tomboy type character
not
not over the top type of tomboy but she
just um
you know she doesn't like care about
getting her nails done or anything like
that um and dick dart is just like not
having it so basically this whole time
he like makes her like while they're on
the run
um because like i said they're both on
the run he has escaped because he's uh
accused serial killer and she's an
accused kidnapper so she can't really
call the cops because she's afraid she's
gonna go to jail too um and also he's
you know will kill her and cut her into
pieces if she does something that he
doesn't like so he like goes and buys
her all of these new clothes and it's
like he does her hair and like she just
does like all of this grooming and like
puts makeup on her because she doesn't
like to wear makeup and all this other
kind of [ __ ] and it's just like this
insane and of course like he
rapes her multiple times and it's just
this whole [ __ ] [ __ ] show so they're
kind of on the road for a while too now
the thing about how the serial killer
thing ties in with
the
uh literary mystery type thing about
hugo driver and night journey and the
stuff that happened at the writer's
retreat back in 1938 is that the serial
killer
he wants to do something like
he's trying to bump off
anybody because they're i guess like one
of the central things is that there's
some kind of question over whether hugo
driver actually wrote night journey or
not or whether he actually stole the
story from another writer like back then
but because hugo driver is you know he
who has since passed away is like this
big um you know it's such a money maker
like for the for the chancel house
publishing company which like i said
nora and her husband's whole family is
involved in there's kind of a thing
where they don't really want if he did
steal the manuscript which like i said
is in doubt um then they don't really
want that getting out so the serial
killer is kind of tied into because he's
sort of like killing people
that maybe knew something about what
happened back then uh because he doesn't
want like the real thing coming out so
there's like a whole uh situation around
that
now like i said this is a very
complex story it's very i mean if you've
read any peter straub i've read like a
lot of his books he has a very
particular
very literary kind of style so if you're
not super down with that then this might
just like seem like a big slog to you
because
it's not i mean his prose is not real
ornate i mean it's not
you know there's not like a lot of
unnecessary stuff really but
he does kind of like
try hard to like establish a mood he has
a lot of sort of literary illusions he
has a lot of connections that you sort
of have to make yourself that you know
that he doesn't really hold your hand
through
so as i said his books are kind of like
not for everyone because they're
you know they're a commitment to read
you can it's not just a real breezy like
beach read where you just kind of skim
through it and be like yep that was good
whatever um that said this is not my
favorite book of his uh that would still
probably be be a ghost story i have a
couple of his other ones um just over
there in the in the tbr pile
that i've read before that i remember
really liking i think in the night room
and maybe lost boy lost girl and i
remember really liking those as well i
think the thing about this one though
it's like i feel like i feel like i
liked it when i read it but i did feel
like back in early 2000s or whenever it
was but another thing too is i kind of
feel like i remember thinking back then
why is this called the hellfire club
because i was thinking it was going to
be about like hellfire clubs in general
and it's not really like there's only a
few mentions of a hellfire club or like
you know one or two of them and it
doesn't have a lot to do with the main
plot it just so it almost kind of seemed
like a side just like a something that
was mentioned a couple times and then so
so i feel like the title was a little
bit of a you know a misnomer but it's
weird because i feel like i liked it
more the first time i read it like this
time around like i liked it but there
were times
when
i was kind of like
man come on let's like get on with it
and it just it's i didn't remember
anything about it so i didn't really
like
remember where it was going or what was
going on so i had totally forgotten
about like the whole kidnapped by a
serial killer and then getting horribly
like raped and stuff um you know i'd
forgotten about that aspect of it and i
just you know i i remembered like the
literary mystery thing but i didn't
really remember the serial killer thing
so much but
i did like
the sort of
character arc of nora i liked her
character a lot although she's
it's weird because i liked her character
but i do kind of feel like she's still
at arm's length like from the reader if
that makes any sense um like i said i
kind of feel like because this isn't
super spelled out like in the book but
the impression i got of her was that
because she had been a nurse in vietnam
because she had seen and because she had
been raped in vietnam and because she'd
seen all these horrible things she had
almost kind of like
turned off her emotions you know i mean
so she was almost kind of like had gone
dead inside and so it's almost kind of
like as the story goes on it's she
becomes
more in touch with her emotions and more
willing to deal with her trauma and her
past and everything like that and kind
of finds her inner strength type of
thing like i said it's not real real
obvious but that did seem to be like a
big through line of her character and i
actually did really like that because i
think she's a really well written
character i think like i said a big
theme of the book too is just like how
all the men in her life have treated her
like her entire life um just in
different like shitty in different ways
like i said not everybody
like she does have some you know a
couple of male friends in there that are
fine uh but
most of the like her husband her
father-in-law you know obviously dick
dart the serial killer like everybody
you know is shitty to her in their own
ways and it's almost kind of like the
through line of the plot like of her
character is coming to terms with how to
like stand on her own two feet and not
let that happen again or you know not
let men treat her that way that's not a
screamingly obvious
thing but if you read the book and
really kind of get into it
you can see that that's kind of what one
of the main themes is but as i said this
is i i didn't love it this time and like
i said i think i liked it better the
first time i read it than this time
because a few times i've
it was a little bit of work to get
through but it's but it is like a good
book overall not my favorite of his uh
which like i said is still a ghost story
i don't think i've ever read anything of
his that i liked more than that but it's
still like a decent read if you really
like complex stories
that are sort of like a genre mashup you
know what i mean because this is kind of
like a literary
mystery the whole thing about hugo
driver did he really
write that book did he steal it from
somebody what happened at shorelands
back then with that writer that
disappeared you know what's going on
with all that and it's also a pretty
gruesome
serial killer kidnapping crime thriller
road trip type of thing too like
halfway so it's kind of an interesting
amalgamation of those two genres so if
that sounds like something that you
would be into i didn't really spoil it
too much other than you know giving you
because i feel like the the the text on
the back
like i said and i think i said this
before in like some of my other reviews
but it's always like the text on the
back is always like vague enough that
you know but but sometimes after you've
read the book and then you read the text
on the back you're like that's not
really what the poem was about i mean it
kind of is but it's hard to like
condense a story this
complex into
like a couple of sentences so
i get that it's hard to write like book
blurbs and everything like that because
you'd really want to like condense the
essence down and like i said something
like this that
is a mixture of different genres and is
also really really complicated and has
like all of these crazy plot threads
that are all sort of interconnected like
a big huge web you know that can be hard
to distill down into
like a real pithy
you know paragraph like on the back of a
book so i get it but i'm just saying
that don't be fooled by it being called
the hellfire club it doesn't really have
a lot to do with with that and don't
take the text on the back or you know
the descriptive text that's on amazon or
whatever don't take that as like oh
that's really what the book is about
it's marginally what the book is about
but there's a whole bunch of other [ __ ]
going on in there too so just know that
going in uh so yeah but it was still a
decent read um i didn't like it as much
this time as i did the first time but it
was still really good and i really got
into some parts of it especially once
she got kidnapped by the serial killer
that was probably the best part but yeah
so check it out if you've read it if you
like peter straub let me know in the
comments and we'll have like a little
discussion about it and that will do it
for this tomes of terror and i will see
you guys on the next one
bye